Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today is a glorious day, because we are going
to witness the first table cloth pull simulation
I have ever seen.
Well, I hoped that it would go a little more
glorious than this.
Maybe if we pull a bit quicker.
Yes, there we go, and…we’re good.
Loving it.
Now, if you are a seasoned Fellow Scholar,
you might remember from about 50 videos ago
that we covered the predecessor of this paper,
called Incremental Potential Contact, IPC
in short.
So, what could it do?
It could perform seriously impressive squishing
experiments.
And it also passed the tendril test, where
we threw a squishy ball at a glass wall, and
watched this process from the other side.
A beautiful, and rare sight indeed.
Unless you have cats and glass tables at home,
of course.
Outstanding.
So, I hear you asking, Károly, are you trying
to say that this new paper tops all that?
Yes, that is exactly what I am saying.
The table cloth pulling is one thing, but
it can do so much more.
You can immediately start holding on to your
papers, and let’s go.
This new variant of IPC is capable of simulating
super thin materials, and all this in a penetration-free
manner.
Now, why is that so interesting or difficult?
Well, that is quite a challenge, remember
this earlier paper with the barbarian ship.
Tons of penetration artifacts.
And that is not even a thin object.
Not nearly as thin as this stack would be.
Let’s see what a previous simulation method
would do with this if these are 10 millimeters
each.
That looks reasonable, now let’s cut the
thickness of the sheets in half.
Yes, some bumpy artifacts appear, and at 1
millimeter, my goodness.
It’s only getting worse.
And, when we plug in the same thin sheets
into the new simulator.
All of them look good, and what’s more,
they can be simulated together with other
elastic objects without any issues.
And this was a low-stress simulation.
If we use the previous technique for a higher-stress
simulation.
This starts out well, until…uh-oh.
The thickness of the cloth is seriously decreasing
over time.
That is not realistic.
But, if we plug the same scene into the new
technique, now that is realistic.
So, what is all this good for?
Well, if we wish to simulate a bowl of noodles,
tons of thick objects, let’s see if we can
hope for an intersection-free simulation.
Let’s look under the hood…and, there we
go!
All of the noodles are separated.
But wait a second, I promised you thin objects,
these are not thin.
Yes, now these, are thin.
Still, no intersections.
That is absolutely incredible.
Other practical applications include simulating
hair.
Braids in particular.
Granular materials against a thin sheet work
too.
And, if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because the
authors promise that we can even simulate
this in-hand shuffling technique in a virtual
world.
Well, I will believe it when I see it.
Let’s see…my goodness.
Look at that.
Love the attention to detail where the authors
color coded the left and right stack so we
can better see how they mix, and if they intersect.
Spoiler alert: they don’t.
What a time to be alive!
It can also simulate this piece of cloth with
a ton of detail, and not only that, with large
timesteps, which means that we can advance
the time after each simulation step in bigger
packets, thereby speeding up the execution
time of the method.
I also love how we get a better view of the
geometry changes as the other side of the
cloth has a different color.
Once again, great attention to detail.
We are still in the minutes per frame region,
and note that this runs on your processor,
therefore, if someone can implement this on
the graphics card in a smart way, it could
become close to real time in at most a couple
papers more down the line.
And, this is a research paper that the authors
give away to all of us, free of charge.
How cool is that.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for creating these miracles
and just giving them away for free.
What a noble endeavor research is!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!